i mean i've tried to do my [__]
hardest to just not be associated with
the whole like
that scene but
i don't know it's like the wolf thing
kind of like put me in the dialogue
because wolves like the goat of that
scene yes but every but there's a lot of
people like underwolf that are
just
just very much so
i feel like what wolf has done for the
for white rappers as well is really
branched out you know what i mean so
it's dope
he's he's brought you up yeah like i'm
glad if anybody co-signed me it was wolf
because he understands respects the
culture has honored the culture like you
know
i [__] hate the rest of that scene to
be real but yeah i'm not gonna lie like
uh
a lot of that uh [__] is cringy as [__]
man i just can't have no mega rappers on
my [__] shots i just i don't like any
of the blurred lines between like
i don't know like the political they're
ripping up black lives matter signs oh
that [__] is crazy that's wild to me
it's like that dude who um i [__]
when i was living in tampa
that [__] weenie [__] who you
were talking [__] to oh the uh the fat
guy
the real fat ugly dude with the tattoos
[Music]
and uh he was from saint pete but nobody
in tampa [__] with him because he was
like a goof but i think he came from
like a rich family or something i don't
know
but then all of a sudden
he's like
a trump rapper he's like a trump rapper
here's the thing that's the craziest
[__] i've ever watched a lot of white
rappers and just people in general they
like find this niche that's going and
then they sell out their whole brand for
this they just dig in because it's like
i one thing i'll i'll take being at the
level that i'm at because you know some
of those guys do numbers now or they're
doing a million views but i'll tell you
what i'll always take being at a lesser
level to keep my integrity high like i i
don't have no desire to like hit certain
number accolades or like you know i
think i'm one of the dopest artists out
there and like my whole mission and
pursuit though is just like on my own
artistic path i'll never sell that short
for some trendy like
thing i don't know i just watch all
these low hanging fruit man exactly i
watch all of them turn from like street
rappers to like trump mega political
right like that's just mad corny they're
just taking advantage of that like whole
movement there's just people that are
like die hard and this [__] is atrocious
it's like the worst music to me all
that's just trash so it's annoying that
i even get like brought into the
dialogue i got all these youtube
channels because you beefed with those
guys though i didn't beat you but you
put this record out
which one didn't you put it this
recorder nice one what do you mean which
one what the [__] are you no you gotta
go
what do you what's what the hell are you
talking about i got time today yes hold
up now that wasn't to get me in the
dialogue of of the white rapper [__]
that was because this bitch-ass
[__] made another record about
that i just was proven that was like me
being in the gym and just being like hey
let me show you that i'm way better than
well those guys are like really bad at
making music so i don't understand any
of it honestly
the whole thing is like i'm just like
it's just like cringe theater rap it's
you know it's like it's like rap that
like you have to watch theater i call it
theater rap cause you gotta watch the
video and listen to the [__]
ridiculous [__] they say and then you'll
never listen to the song shout out to
the qa non-rap sub category [__] olly up
please
please diss me some more so that i can
be separated further from y'all's fan
base i have no desire to be associated
with y'all i don't want to make y'alls
type of music i think all of y'all are
trash and none of y'all could see me on
the mic so
the more time i've had being sober the
more like man i'm focused on my family
my health my music [__] on mega
rappers and
well leave those guys alone
i just they gonna i've been i've been on
youtube come at me man
this motherfucker's head telling him
like he's like he's like stop
associating yourself with them i'm like
i [__] hate them let me just stop
acknowledging them because i told them
they're gonna put you in there because i
was like they're gonna associate you
with that [__] even if you just yeah
just leave them alone but he wrecked him
we did it in like
we made that song in 30 minutes [__] on
his life video and then like all the
other [__] like calhoun and these
[__] weirdos they just made vlogs
about me they don't want to dis anymore
some super weenies man and that dude's
like 50.
i was what's funny is that i made a joke
to my homies like he won't want rap
smoke he'll go make a youtube vlog and
that's what he did and i was just like i
won just off of that
i don't know i don't make vlogs about
people
i'm like oh if i don't like you i'ma
just avoid i'm over here
there leave me the [__] alone they're
over there
[Music]
no part of that way keep all that weirdo
[__] away from me that's why i like you
know because like my guys are like you
dooby ritz
sometimes we're like we're like
we're like interviewing we're from the
south where we're from well we have some
overlapping fans because i'm from
florida we're from the south blue white
jelly roll's my dog and i know jelly
rolls friends and there's people that's
like yeah like i don't yeah whoever want
to be friends with them to me i didn't
do nothing wrong like all those
[__] came at me because i said
we was the hardest since shady but i
feel like everybody think they're the
hardest say they're the hardest dude
like every one of those guys at some
point talk about how they're the bed
like
i thought all that [__] was corny like
they tried to like start some [__] with
me
that was all for the internet you know
cause like if you really got an issue
with somebody you gonna talk to him
you're gonna see him be about some [__]
you know make up edit your [__] vlog
at your house and
uh [__] spend an hour [__] editing
this clip